[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the 5 000 people
following us for this press conference
to present climate change 2021
the physical science basis which is the
working group one contribution to the
ipcc's sixth assessment report
today we have with us the heads of the
ipcc's two parent organizations inger
anderson
executive director of the united nations
environment program unit and pedry tulas
secretary general of the wmo world
meteorological organization
we also have the chair of the ipcc
wasting li the two co-chairs of working
group one valerie masson delmar and pan
mao
and the secretary of the ipcc abdullah
moxit
we also have several members of the
working group one bureau who are
available for questions and i'll
introduce them later
we're going to start with brief opening
remarks from our panelists and then a
presentation of the new report by the
co-chairs and then there'll be plenty of
time for questions and answers
this press conference can be followed by
the public registered media can ask
questions if you do please include your
name and your outlet i'd now invite
abdallah to introduce the press
conference abdallah
thank you junatan
i am pleased
and proud
to welcome you all
to this virtual press conference
it follows
something unique
and unprecedented for the ipcc and for
many other international organizations
we have just completed
a virtual approval session
virtually you know
session you know but a virtual approval
session it is the first one in the
history
i want to highlight this it is the first
virtual approval session
not only was
it
the first in ipcc history
it was also
one
of the few approval session
that did not run
into extra time
and probably
with the largest
participation of delegates
when we first realized over a year ago
that the pandemic
met first forced us to hold a virtual
session
many said it was impossible
it was impossible
people raised concern about connectivity
problems as well as inclusivity as well
as transparency
into ipcc secretaria who works
intensively with our bureau and with the
working group one
bureau in
an exhaustive consultation with
our member government to find a format
that would be consistent with the values
and principle of the ipcc
ipcc should have a neutral and policy
neutral outcome
and we succeeded
i am proud to say that we succeeded
we succeeded
over two weeks
we worked calmly and efficiently
without a technical hitch no zero
technical hits
this is something to flag
whatever time was scheduled a session
was unsocial
hours for someone we had
delegates
and authors joining from utc plus 13
hours
like in summer
2
utc minus 7 hours
in the north
american west coast
our participants
clocked up
186
hours on virtual platform
during this two weeks
and
they were working an average of
12.6
hours a day
i should not reveal
that to you that what it said in closed
ipcc meeting
but i can't tell you
that many delegates
in their closing statements said that
this was
the most successful ipcc approval
session they couldn't remember
just to have flag that's
in this comparison they include even the
personal the plenary in person that
means it's a this virtual one was the
best one compared to even other physical
ones
we had a rocker
of attendance of
739 participants
and this is really record we never have
in in-person plenary that's number of
participants
and
as you are about to hear the result
was one of the strongest
and most significant
report of the in the ipcc has re
produced
and this report for working group one is
coming
to fill the basket the package of the
sixth cycle
for which we are
producing eighth report
making this sixth cycle the most intense
the most rich in the ipcc history once
again it is a recall
i would like to take this opportunity
to thank
the working group one co-chair valerie
and panmau
i want also to thank bureau members
the 200
authors and also the technical support
unit team the working group one as the
others as well
and also
i want to thank very harmley
my small secretariat
which is like a
behind
working
non-stop
we have no time zone for ipcc
ipcc secretary i want also
i want to like to thank harmony our
parent organization
and also
yes i want to thank our chair
for his leadership
through all this process
in this six cycle
we are making
a story
so i want to thank all the one who
contributed
in background to this process
so with this word
i want to turn to jonathan jonathan you
have the floor
thank you uh thank you abdullah and we
now have um over 7 000 people following
us on this press conference and i'll
invite you in there to make some opening
remarks
thank you very much and let me just echo
what abdullah just said a warm and
sincere thanks to everyone who has been
involved in this
to the ipcc to the authors
and to everyone who's been involved in
in this latest climate alarm
your work based on science
is particularly appreciated given the
disruption of covet 19.
you've been telling us for over three
decades of the dangers of allowing the
planets warm
the world listened but didn't hear
the world listened but it did not act
strongly enough
and as a result
climate change is a problem that is here
now
nobody's safe
and it's getting worse faster
we must treat climate change as an
immediate threat
just as we must treat the connected
crisis of nature and biodiversity loss
and pollution and waste as immediate
threats
as recently noted in the ipcc and the
intergovernmental science policy
platform and biodiversity and ecosystem
services it best the twin to ipcc if you
like under the cbd convention
we understand that climate change
exacerbates already grave risks to
biodiversity and natural managed
habitats
ecosystem degradation damages nature's
ability to reduce the force of climate
change
and as the ipcc working group one report
reminds us
reducing greenhouse gases will not only
slow climate change
but will improve air quality
it's all connected
it's time to get serious because every
ton of co2 emission adds to global
warming
as a unf triple c noted last week
110 countries just 110 out of 191
parties to the convention have submitted
new or updated ndc's ahead of the next
climate club
governments
need to make their net zero plan an
integral part of their paris commitments
they must finance and support developing
countries to adapt to climate change as
promised under the paris agreement
they must decarbonize faster
they must restore natural systems and
draw down carbon
cut out methane and other greenhouse
gases faster get behind the kigali
amendment to the montreal protocol to
cut the climate impact of the cooling
industry
and every business every investor and
every citizen
needs to play their part
we can't undo the mistakes of the past
but this generation of political and
business leaders
this generation of conscious citizens
can make things right
this generation
can make the systemic changes that will
stop the planet warming help everyone
adapt to the new conditions
and create
a world of peace prosperity and equity
climate change is here now
but we
are also here now and if we don't act
who will thank you
thank you very much singer and now i'd
invite pettery to take the floor
thank you jonathan and thanks for
inviting me to
for this opening of this important
session
wmo organized the first world climate
consult conference over in 1979
to establish
ipcc
the risk of climate change was caused by
growing consumption of oil coal and
natural gas was recognized by the
meteorological community
ipcc has been working under wm1unip
since then
and wmo has been proud to host ipcc
secretariat
now we are publishing the physical
science
part of the sixth assessment report
which is summarizing the results
published in peer-reviewed scientific
literature during the last eight years i
would like to thank hundreds of authors
and reviewers of the of this massive
report and especially i'd like to thank
valerie
masson delmot and panmar zai
who have been leading the work
and have devoted several years of their
career for for ipcc
you will soon hear the main findings of
this report
the key messages are still the same
as in the first ipcc report which was
published already in
1988
namely climate sense is
already detected by using several
measured physical parameters
secondly the human induced emissions of
greenhouse gases especially carbon
dioxide will pose a threat
for human well-being and for the
biosphere and thirdly reduction of the
emissions of greenhouse gases
would be needed and recommended to
minimize the risks of future climate
change
the report published today echoes the
same messages with much higher urgency
climate change is already more visible
and their missions have grown more than
more rapidly than we ever expected in
1979 i've been i had a chance to follow
this
also personally as a scientist since the
80s
and professor and and also chair of the
national
ipcc committee and
national delay gate
natural variability has always been
causing weather extremes and we will do
so also in the future
it's just close the tokyo olympic games
uh yesterday
by using sports terms one could say that
the atmosphere has been exposed to
doping
it means that we have begun
observing climate extremes more often
than before
that means record breaking temperatures
drought forest fires
observed also this year and also during
these days
increase in california for example we
have also more water vapor into
atmosphere which has led to severe
flooding problems as observed in central
europe and china recently with
several casualties unfortunately
the warming of the oceans has affected
the frequency and area of existence of
the most
intense tropical storms hurricanes
typhoons and
cyclos
have we lost the hope
no one yes according to this report we
are we are still having a chance to stop
the negative climate trend
during the mid
of this century
by especially limiting the use of fossil
fuels and by stopping deforestation
some changes will continue for centuries
and or even thousands of years like sea
level rise
melting of glaciers and thinking of
arctic
sea ice and snow cover
the report underlines thirds the thirst
and seas to enhance the ambition level
of climate
mitigation
we are not yet heading towards paris
limits 1.5 to 2 degrees
warming by the end of this century
at un our aim is to reach a 1.5 degree
warming level which would be best for
the welfare of mankind and
biosphere
now we are heading towards two to three
degrees
warming instead
we have
received encouraging plexus by several
countries
this would mean about 2.1 degree warming
if materialized as promised
this is not enough to avoid several
harmful harmful impacts
like loss of food production capacity
other sodies
extreme heat forest fires
continued sea level rise
potential of refugee crisis
and the negative impacts on world
economy and biosphere
besides climate mitigation it is
essential to pay at the pay attention to
climate adaptation
since the negative trending climate will
continue for decades
and in some cases for thousands of years
one powerful way to adapt to uh is to
invest in early morning climate and
water services
only half of the 193 members of wmo
have such services in place
which means more human and economic
losses
we have also severe gaps in weather and
hydrological observing networks
especially in africa some parts of latin
america and in the pacific and caribbean
island states it is a major which has a
major negative impact
on the accuracy of weather forecasts in
those areas
but also worldwide
the message of the ipcc report is
crystal clear
we have to raise the ambition level of
mitigation
the forthcoming cop 26 meeting in
glasgow this november will be a critical
milestone to combat climate change
by using sports terms again
we need the spirit sport sport
already during this decade not just
before the finish
as we do at the running competitions
thank you
thank you pettery and i now invite
huistung to introduce the report
[Music]
thank you jonathan
firstly i'd like to recall that today is
the international day of
the world's indigenous peoples ipcc
assessments
draws on
respect draws on enormously and also to
respect indigenous knowledge all over
the world
we recognize that traditional
agricultural practices can be resilient
to climate and non-climate stressors and
indigenous knowledge systems and
practices allow local people to accept
to to adapt to many climatic changes
i would also like to inform you that
this report is dedicated
to the memory of sir john hewton
one of the key figures in the creation
of the ipcc in 1988
who served as chair and co-chair of
rookie group 1 and who died in april
last year
and the interactive atlas one of the
innovative aspects of this report
is dedicated to the memory of
gemma teresa narisma
one of its coordinating lead authors who
sadly passed away in march this year
the report that we are presenting today
is the result of an unprecedented effort
by the ipcc community
on top of the intense efforts required
for any ipcc report
we have faced the challenge of
completing the assessment in a pandemic
which obliged us to shoulder not only
extra work but develop new ways of
working to get the job done
this was an unprecedented effort but we
finished on time
with greater participation than usual
and have delivered strong clear
scientific assessment of climate change
many thanks to the authors who took on
this
responsibility to deliver the report and
to the working group one bureau
technical support unit and the ipcc
secretariat who made this possible
let me also thank the government of
france and china
for their generous support
of the tsu and of spain for support of
the interactive atlas
and thanks to our member governments
who provided us with the necessary
guidance so that we could hold a virtual
approval session and then participated
in the meeting in the spirit of
cooperation and collegiality to prove
the report
ipc's reports are for palace makers and
it is particularly rewarding to see the
wealth of policy relevant information in
this report for instance
the regional focus and regional data
that will support policy makers and
their decisions
this focus on regional information with
new chapters and the interactive atlas
is one of the many innovative innovative
aspects of the report others include
dedicated chapters on human influence on
climate and on the interaction of a
changing climate with extreme weather
events
this report will serve as a timely new
evidence base for
negotiators
at the cup 26 negotiations starting in
less than three months
it will be a valuable toolbox for
negotiators as they consider the level
of ambition at top 26 and together with
the rest of the sixth assessment report
as they prepare for the global start
take
this report climate change 2021 the
physical science-based basis expands our
knowledge of attribution of climate
change
including the human contribution to
extreme weather events
and it provides us with an improved
understanding of climate change
including warming past present and
future
first it tells us that it is
indisputable that human activities are
causing climate change and making
extreme weather events more frequent and
severe
second it shows that climate change is
affecting every region on our planet
and lastly it explains that strong rapid
sustained reductions in carbon dioxide
and other greenhouse gas emissions would
be required to limit global warming
my colleagues valerie and panmau will
now give you a more detailed account i
hand back to jonathan
thank you very much reyson and i now
invite valerie and panmau to present the
new report please bear with us for a few
seconds while we switch the presentation
thank you jonathan
before we get on
to presenting the findings of the ipcc
six assessment report on the physical
science basis of climate change
i'm proud to unveil the artwork that is
featured on the cover page of the report
an artist created this piece of visual
art on this front cover having been
inspired by a scientific figure in our
summary for policymakers this global
view highlights one of the most
important message from this report that
climate change is already affecting
every region on our planet
and every fraction of additional warming
will increasingly affect every region in
multiple ways
the ipcc
does not conduct new research itself
instead
the hundreds of scientists who worked on
this report come together to assess
their current state of knowledge
of the science of climate change then
reviewed over 14 000 studies
massive amounts of data
in this assessment
we welcome the new authors two-thirds of
whom
had never been involved as an author
of previous ipcc reports
our team was made up of scientists
from 66 countries around the world
in this review in the review process
three phases of review
by governments and experts we took on
board over
78 thousand comments from experts and
the governments
all review comments are addressed by the
authors
and because of the pandemic
these meetings
moved online and we had to invent an
entirely new way of working
which ended up
in this
appreciate and
unprecedented
online approval process
over the last two weeks
people said we couldn't do it
but we did
since the last assessment report in 2013
they have been important advances in
climate science worldwide during these
years climate scientists filled in gaps
in observations of past climates they
improved climate models and developed
new ways to combine many types of
evidence
as a result today we have the clearest
picture of how the earth's climate
functions
and how human activities affect it
we know better than ever how the climate
has changed in the past how it is
changing now
and how it will change in the future
of course
we have known for decades that the world
is warming
but the recent changes we have seen
in the climate are now widespread rapid
and intensifying
some of the changes
we see today
are unprecedented in thousands of years
or never seen before
the recent rate of warming
is unprecedented
in the
in at least 2 000 years
to measure how the climate is changing
we looked at
a key indicate the average temperature
of the earth's surface
over a period of at least a decade
compared to the average in the late
1800s
if we took
at the last 10 years the average surface
temperature was 1.1 degree celsius
warmer
in fact
each of the last four decades
has successfully been the warmest since
the late 1800s
temperature is not only expect that is
being altered
levels
of heat trapping gases in the atmosphere
continue to increase fast
current co2 concentrations
are the highest
they have been
for at least 2 million years
over the past 100 years
sea level sea level has risen
at faster rates than it ever
did in at least the 3000 years
some arctic sea ice area
is at its lowest
in at least 1 000 years
under the retreat of glaciers on global
scale since 1950
is unprecedented in at least 2 000 years
that warming
we have already experienced
has far reaching consequences
climate change
is contributing to increase in extreme
heat
heavy precipitation event
and a drought
since 1950s
hot extremes
including heat waves over land and the
marine heat wave
have become
more frequent and more intense
heavy precipitation events have become
more frequent and more intense
and we see increasing drought
in some regions
these consequences
to heat rainfall and the drought
touch our whole planet
not just people
but also plants and animals
both nature and agriculture
the growing season of plants has
lessened
on average
in large parts of the northern
hemisphere
firewood
the combination of dry
hot and windy conditions
that is
conducive to wildfire is becoming more
frequent in many parts of the world
multiple changes are taking place
in ocean
which is warming acidifying and losing
oxygen
affecting ocean life and the people who
depend on it
there will be further warming in the
coming decades
what is clear from this report is that
unless there are immediate strong rapid
and large scale reductions in greenhouse
gas emissions
limiting global warming to 1.5 degrees
celsius
will be beyond reach
the report shows that
in the next 20 years
global warming
the average temperature at the earth's
surface over a period of 20 years is
expected to reach or exceed 1.5 degrees
celsius above the late 1800s
however
if we rapidly reduce greenhouse gas
emissions
if we can reach global net zero co2
emissions around 2050
it is extremely likely that we can keep
global warming well below 2 degrees
if we do this it is more likely than not
that temperature would gradually decline
to below or around 1.5 degrees celsius
by the end of the century with a
temporary overshoot of no more than 0.1
degrees
celsius but if global greenhouse gas
emissions
remain around today's levels in the
coming decades
we would reach two degrees of global
warming
by the middle of this century
with every additional amount of global
warming
we will see greater changes in the
climate
every additional half degree of warming
will cause increases in the intensity
and frequency of hot extremes
heavy precipitation and drought
at two degrees of global warming heat
extremes would more often reach critical
tolerance thresholds for agriculture and
human health
at a global scale
extreme daily rainfall events intensify
by about seven percent for each
additional degree celsius of global
warming
as you see
future further changes depend on future
human influence
now panmau let's go back to where we are
today
it is it is
disputable that human activities
it is
indisputable that human activities have
caused and are causing climate change
that what what's new in this report is
that we now have a much more advanced
understanding
of the connections between the emissions
we release
and the rise in global surface
temperature and the change to weather
and the climate we are seeing around the
world
it is unequivocal that human influence
has warmed the atmosphere
ocean and the land almost all the
observed warming
from the late 1800s
is human caused
in this report
we looked at all the atmospheric gases
that affect the climate
we confirm that human cost emissions
of greenhouse gases
are the main drive of global warming
and we can see clearly how much warming
comes from carbon dioxide methane and
other greenhouse gases
we can also
assess the influence of pollution
particles that call aerosols which have
an overall cooling effect
this cooling effect
partly masks the warming from the
greenhouse gases
we also looked at all the natural
factors that can affect the climate
will take into account how natural
climate variability
modulates human cost change at the
regional scales
with little effect on global warming at
the central scale
another major advance in our
understanding of human emissions
is how our
emissions lead to specific changes in
the climate
including extreme weather and climate
events
we know today that human influence is
already making extreme
weather in the climate events
including heat waves heavy precipitation
and the droughts
more frequent
and
more severe
hot extremes
including heat waves have become more
frequent and more intense
since 1950s
and some recent hot extremes
in the last decade
would have been extremely unlikely
without human influence on the climate
system
furthermore we know that human influence
has been the main driver of ocean
warming since
1970s and our human-caused co2 emissions
are the main driver
of ocean
acidification
human influence
in contributing
to reduced
oxygen levels in the ocean observed
since the mid 20th century
human influence is also the main driver
of change we see
in the frozen areas of the planet the
cryosphere
driving
the global retreat
of glaciers since the 1990s
the 40 percent decrease in active sea
arctic sea ice since 1979
and a decrease in spring snow cover
since the 1950s
it is very likely that the human
influence contributed to surface melt of
greenland ice sheet in last 20 years
these advances
in our understanding of how human
activities are affecting their climate
mean that today we can better estimate
the change we may experience
both gradual trains and extremes
resulting from
different amounts of emissions different
levels of warming and across different
regions
climate change
is already affecting every region on
earth
in multiple ways
but climate change manifests
differently depending on where
in the world you are
there are different combinations of
change
in every part of the world
in this report
we added more
new information that is useful
on a regional
scale this is an area of climatic
climate science
that has rapidly advanced in the last 10
years
to reflect to reflect this
and provide more information helpful to
inform decisions
related to risk management and
adaptation
around a third of our report
is dedicated to regional climate
information
as a part of our folks on regional
climate information
we also
introduce a new concept
of climatic impact drivers
to help translate physical changes in
climate
heat
cold
rain
drought snow wind coastal flooding and
more
into what they mean for the
society and the ecosystems
are not only looking at gradual
temperature increases
but also at the aspect
but also at the specific conditions
where heat goes over thresholds
known to lead to severe consequences for
people
agriculture and a wild life
many of the changes were assessed
are related to
the global water cycle
their water cycle means how water moves
through the atmosphere land
ocean and the cryosphere
with warmer temperatures the atmosphere
can hold more water
now we see more and faster evaporation
and the heavier precipitation
the monsoon rainfalls
which are also important
to so many peoples
are changing
in a complex way
in response to
the contrasting effects of both
greenhouse gases
and approaching particles which we call
aerosols
with more global warming the global
water cycle will intensify
that means
both heavy rainfall at the same time
as we see intensifying drying seasons
and droughts
with more global warming
average annual rainfall on land
is expected to increase
but that rainfall is expected to become
more valuable within a season
and from year to year
the interactive atlas
longitude today
makes our global and the regional
climate information
available to all
it includes observations of ongoing
change
the projections of future changes
and you can see the interactive atlas to
make your own maps
you can use interactive atlas to make it
your own
maps and analysis
using the datasets we used in the report
you can use
interactive atlas to find out what
climate change
means for where you live
i'll be back to you
thank you
moreover many of the changes set in
motion by human-caused climate change
are slow processes
these long-lasting changes for most part
affect the planet's frozen regions the
cryosphere and the ocean
changes in ice sheets deep ocean
temperature and acidification will
continue for centuries to thousands of
years
meaning that they are irreversible in
our lifetime and will continue for
generations to come
in this report we show that
over the course of this century
global ocean temperature is projected to
raise 2 to 8 times as much as it has
increased since the early 1970s
the melting of the greenland and
antarctica ice sheets will continue for
thousands of years
this means that sea level will keep
rising
coming back to today
the rate of sea level
rise keeps increasing
and the rate of ice sheet loss has
increased by a factor of 4 in the past
30 years
the good news is that these irreversible
changes can be slowed down
with rapid
strong
and sustained reductions in emissions
and other changes
can be stopped if greenhouse gas
emissions are deeply reduced
for example
retreating glaciers and arctic sea ice
will continue to decline for at least
several decades
but these changes could be slowed and
stopped if emissions are reduced
to limit global warming strong rapid and
sustained reductions in co2 methane and
other greenhouse gases are necessary
we know that co2 carbon dioxide
is the key greenhouse gas driving
climate change
we know it comes
from the most part
from the burning of fossil fuels
this report reaffirms that there is a
near linear relationship
between the cumulative amount of
emissions of co2 in the atmosphere from
human activities
and the extent of observed and future
warming
this is physics
this means that the only way to limit
global warming
is to reach net zero co2 emissions at
the global scale every additional ton of
co2 emissions
adds to global warming
our report gives more details on how
reducing emissions will affect the
climate
for instance it quantifies just how much
more co2 we can release
and still have a chance to limit warming
close to 1.5 degrees celsius or 2
degrees celsius
we know that today
around half of our co2 emissions
are taken up and stored by plants soils
and ocean
we assess how these processes change
with future emissions
and we know now that if we release ever
greater amounts of co2
these natural carbon sinks
would actually take up a smaller
proportion of our future emissions
this report also shows that while co2 is
the dominant greenhouse gas related to
human influence on climate
and reaching net zero co2 is required to
limit global warming
strong reductions in other greenhouse
gas emissions are needed
amongst these
methane reductions together with strong
air pollution controls
would benefit both the climate
and improve air quality
our planet
is warming
and it is warming quickly
with increasing consequences everywhere
this report is clear that it is possible
to limit future warming within a few
decades
the climate we experience in the future
depends on our decisions now
thank you
thank you very much uh valerie in panama
and we're now ready to take questions
from registered media um we already have
quite a few in so i expect we'll be
running the q a session until half past
11 geneva paris time
a reminder that media should include
their name and outlet with any questions
they submit
besides the panelists who have already
spoken we have several members of the
working group one bureau who are
available to
respond to questions too they are jan
fuglesvet carolina vera
fantarek fatima drewesh edwin aldrian
and greg flatto
so
i'll go to the first question now which
is from torshia kaba of the tokyo
shimbun newspaper who's asking about the
effect of the coronavirus pandemic on
climate change
valerie would you like to sign that
um yes uh thank you for the question so
our report shows that
due to the lockdown
implemented
in the pandemic context there have been
temporary reductions in emissions of co2
a few percent at the global scale
but these are temporary reductions um
we're not sufficient to have a
significant impact and therefore the
rise in atmospheric co2 concentration in
the atmosphere has continued
moreover
there have been reductions in emissions
of air pollutants temporary reductions
as well leading to immediate
improvements in air quality these are
the two aspects
related to the pandemic that are
assessed in this report
thank you
valerie and the next question comes from
sung wook park of jtvc
who says that many countries have
committed to
carbon neutral net zero 2050 but as we
know greenhouse gases especially carbon
dioxide lasts hundreds of years once
emitted will it be possible to keep
temperatures within 1.5 or 2 degrees in
2050 or this century as a whole
again valerie please
um thank you jonathan so in this report
the assessment is based on five
scenarios and the assessed response of
of global temperature
this report shows that in all the
assessed scenarios
global warming would reach or exceed 1.5
degrees celsius in the coming two
decades
however
if emissions are reduced
rapidly and if at the global scale they
reach net zero by around 2050 then
temperature would be very close to 1.5
degrees celsius
by the mid of the century and would
decline lower to that level by the end
of the century
so this is what we provide and we
provide an updated understanding of how
the climate responds to emissions
and and this is a a critical information
that is available to inform decision
making worldwide
thank you valerie
pet petteria you do you want to come in
on that
no um okay then third question is from
uh andy revkin of revkin bulletin who
says some climate campaigners and
scholars including at least one
long-time ipcc author criticized the
panel process as erring on quote the
side of least drama unquote is that is
that valid
maybe valerie you want to start on that
but i expect others might want to come
in
um i would like to thank the authors of
the report the hundreds of scientists
for um all their efforts to ensure that
the report reflects the wealth of
available climate information and
provides a balanced assessment of where
we are and where we could go
for that purpose the report provides our
best estimates for instance for the
climate response
it also provides
a complete description including what is
extremely important for risk management
it is the
events that have a small chance of
occurring but could lead to very large
scale impacts and therefore the report
also provides information on very rare
climate extreme events or multiple
events occurring at the same time that
are very important to consider
it also explores what could happen in
the case where
poorly understood processes leading to
the antarctic ice sheet collapse would
start to occur
and therefore the report also provides
high-end estimates for what sea level
rise could be in this type of situation
and this information was requested by
decision makers because it's extremely
important for those who manage critical
infrastructure and the report provides a
wealth of information that can be useful
and actionable for decision makers to
take into account all the scale of risk
especially those
taking decisions related to critical
infrastructure
thank you valerie
please
simply to add that the drama is playing
out in the front pages of the newspapers
today
in terms of climate impacts that we're
seeing already
so this is a scientific report and we've
already heard from dr messen
and and dr zai
but i think as as citizens and as
businesses and as governments we're well
aware of the drama
and so the drama exists we have seen it
and we heard about it in every news
bulletin
and that's what we need to understand
that the expression of what the science
says is exhibited before our very eyes
and of course what this excellent report
does is it projects these scenarios
outward
and tells us
if we do not take action uh what could
be the potential outcomes or if we do
take action what will be a very good
outcome so the the power is in our hands
at this point thank you
thank you pettery
yeah so i've been following this process
since 88 and
and and and and of course these findings
of this report they are not comfortable
so
so and that's why it's important to pass
these messages for decision makers and
general public and of course
we have
the fact that sometimes media is
speaking only those most negative things
and and more recently
there have been attacks
against ipcc saying that ipcc's
reports are too mild so
in the past we were having very much
this kind of skeptical
attacks against science and ipcc itself
but but more recently
some people are saying that these
reports are too mild so
and
and i think that's a little bit
demonstrating that we're on the right
track and this is very much based on
extremely solid science it's not based
on
individual scientific papers but it's
it's a balanced view of the of the
maturity of of science and and i i would
like to encourage you to trust
those results
thank you patrick carolina
thank you i would like to take the
opportunity to also point it out a
different aspect that
the report allows the society we to move
away from that perfect perception that
we are shifting from the same song to
one where we experience dramatic changes
everywhere overnight
the report clearly shows that we are
living the consequences already of
climate change everywhere
but a furthermore that we will
experience further and concurrent and
multiple changes that increase with
every additional bit of warming we
should be prepared for that thank you
thank thank you carolina
okay uh next question from john cannon
of [ __ ] bay the authors say the ocean
and land carbon sinks aren't likely to
be as effective at slowing carbon
dioxide accumulation
is that just to do with the proportion
of carbon they can pull out of the
atmosphere or might it be due to changes
in oceans and tropical rainforests
affecting how they take up carbon
henry
thank you so in this report
we explore
the response of the ocean and land
carbon things
to
the effects of different scenarios of
human greenhouse gas emissions
especially the role of co2
and a major finding is that today the
ocean and land sinks
give us a huge service by storing around
56 percent of the 40
billion tons co2 we emit in the
atmosphere every year
and another finding is that
their relative efficiency at absorbing a
fraction of our emissions
would reduce if we emitted
higher and higher amounts of co2 in the
atmosphere the report also looks at how
they would react
if we stabilize and reduce gets to net
zero or net negative co2 emissions so
this is taken into account in the
assessment for instance of the remaining
carbon budgets related to stabilizing
warming at specific levels
thank you
um
and a question from holly chick of the
south china morning post
what role does china play in combating
climate change as the world's largest
greenhouse gas emitter
and uh yeah that's the first question
from her um panmal could you take that
one please
thank you jonathan
ander
since
ipcc
is assessing you know
not in a position to
assess climate change or actions
for individual member countries
and way more focus on you know global
and the region of perspective and for
working group one
we also you know
more focus on physical science
however in this assessment report we
paid much attention on the regional
information
as i
already
reported
about one third of information
yes for the region now
for the region now
so for
the region of china that's part of east
asia east asia we see
a lot of extreme events happening
the heat wave have increased
and also project to continue
in the future and the daily
precipitation extremes
increased over the past mainly parts of
the region
and also
they may see intensify
and a strong
influence of
the tropical cyclones
naturality has become more frequent and
more
even more severe
in several parts of the area
and i think uh
there so a lot of original information
helped us into
this time to address the region of the
impacts
that's
merely to add um that the g20 countries
bear a special responsibility
uh together they are nearly uh
responsible for around
80 percent of all global emissions um
when we take out land-based sources and
accordingly therefore have a unique
opportunity to really help
in reducing co2 and greenhouse gas
emissions this is based on unip's
emissions gap report which we issue
every year around cop
and so simply to say that the g7 and the
g20 and that includes in the latter
obviously china but includes another 19
countries bear a special responsibility
and we certainly urge them in their
upcoming heads of state summit uh to
live up to uh
uh the facts uh that are on the table
right now and to submit ambitious ndc's
thank you
thank you huh
okay a question from kiyoshi ando of
nikki it seems impossible to limit the
temperature rise to below or equal to
1.5 degrees
unless we follow scenario ssp 1 1.9 for
many countries that hurdle is too high
and this could make them just forget
about the paris agreement how could you
avoid such risks
valerie
thank you jonathan
what i would like to stress is the
following um the report is very clear
the science is very clear that um what
drives further warming compared to today
is
future emissions so this is really in
our hands
and
when you look at the low emission
scenarios from the report and the very
low emission scenario from the report
they share common characteristics
rapid declines in in the rate of
greenhouse gas emissions at the global
scale in this decade in the coming
decades and and reaching net zero for
the lowest one in 2050 and for the low
one in the 2070s
the second one the low emission
scenarios
leads to limiting warming well below 2
degrees celsius the first one leads to
limiting warming very close to 1.5
degrees celsius within 0.1 degrees
so this is what we provide as an
precise
robust scientific information to inform
decision making
thank you valerie
okay i have uh two questions which are
similar so i'll give them both and they
can be answered together one is from
kate nicole williams of tv new zealand
how much stronger is this report and the
world's understanding of the impact of
climate change than the 2013 report
cycle what are the key changes in
understanding
and olivia rudgard of the telegraph asks
are things worse than we thought how did
the conclusions in this report both in
terms of the scale and pace of
human-caused climate change and the
severity of its impacts compared to what
was found in previous reports in 2018
and 2014.
i think that's for you valerie but
others might want to connect to you
thank you very much my understanding of
the question it is that it is first
related to advances in science
understanding and i would like to find
uh to stress a very important progress
in understanding
um the way we describe the climate
response to greenhouse gas emissions is
associated with a an important
measure which is called climate
sensitivity basically climate
sensitivity describes how the climate
responds in terms of forming when you
double the concentration of co2 in the
atmosphere
and scientists have been working on this
issue since the late 1970s and the range
associated with the response of the
climate system was about the same
since the 1970s
but recently thanks to important
scientific advances especially the
understanding of feedbacks and
especially cloud feedbacks
the range of climate sensitivity has
been reduced therefore we had a much
more accurate understanding of the
response of the global climate to
emissions and this is a major advance
that is reflected in this report
it is one of the many examples in fact
of scientific progress
you can find in our technical summary a
two-page summary of the major scientific
advances compared to past ipcc reports
and regarding the second part of the
question
we've known for a long time that with
more emissions
climate would continue to change
and
this report confirms
with a
more robust findings that for instance a
higher rate of greenhouse gas emissions
leads to a higher rate of warming and
that this leads to an increase in the
intensity and frequency of extremes
i would like to flag that on these
aspects we have a much clearer picture
of the regional consequences that in
fact scale with the level of global
warming and this is clearly reflected in
our interactive atlas which brings
together information from global climate
models that have advanced with higher
resolution and also regional climate
models that are important to provide
finer information at regional scales and
this is also a major advance
journey can i add
yes please i know yeah i think you know
uh we also have several aspects very
important one is uh say we assessed we
we we we
we find the recent change
recent climate changes are now
widespread rapid
and intensifying even some of the
changes
we see today
are unprecedented in thousands of years
i think that's very strong another is
about the human uh contribution
which says it is an equivocal of
that human influence has warmed the
atmosphere land and the ocean you know
that means
something like the human activity has
influenced
not only temperature but the whole
uh whole climate system
and
when we put
all the literature and the so many
artists together then we see the whole
picture for the for for for the
the earth system the climate system
and that is quite strong i think it's
much stronger than ar5 which were said
something like
you know the attribution you know more
than half of the wormy attributed to the
human causes i think
that's another advances
and also we see climate changes already
affecting
the older regions on earth in multiple
ways
i think that's also you know something
like influence every
everybody we we live in the earth
and also they
reported clearly state that it is
possible to limit future warming within
a few decades
so that's my addition thank you
thank you panmar fatima
yeah
one thing i would like to highlight also
is uh furthermore to the original
information more regional information we
have in this report we have also the
focused on the climate services which is
an important
aspect that
is able to
help and inform
for a decision
making and adaptation at
several time skills so the climate
services are very important aspects
they are able to as i say i have said to
help for adaptation for risk reduction
and even
for
evaluating
the effect of mitigation on
extremes and on yeah on weather and
climate extremes and i think this is an
important aspect in this report thank
you
thank you fatima carolina
thank you
i would like also to to describe a short
uh
important contribution that i think this
report has that is the quantification of
the projected changes in extremes for
example uh one of the conclusions the
projected changes in extremes are larger
than frequency and intensity but it also
provide quantitative information about
how the frequency intensity change let's
say for a 10-year event of hot
temperature extreme that the
independential periods occur once in 10
years uh the projection shows that we
likely occur for example five uh and
even six times more in the two-degree
world and
another important example for
decision-making uh heavy precipitation
events over land like those that
occurred a 10-year er with a recurrency
sorry of 10 years now in a two
degree a future global warming level
will likely occur almost two times more
frequent thank you
thank you carolina
okay one from marie noel bertrand
this fixed report is easier to read and
understand than the preceding ones more
pedagogic concrete and regionally
illustrated
is this for people to understand it
better or for the politicians to finally
understand
valerie yes
for this report we have
been extremely careful
to explain the outcome of advances of
complex climate science in the clearest
possible way
and therefore
it is reflected not just in the entire
report which has frequently asked
questions that are explained in plain
language
but also in the summary for policy
makers
and you can note that the main headline
statements our key scientific findings
are expressed in plain language so that
they are accessible to everyone we also
worked hard to make sure that figures
could be intuitively understood thanks
to work from specialists of faker design
as well as the authors of the report
and what we really would like
is that this whole report helps enhance
climate literacy worldwide is used in
teaching
worldwide for teenagers for students so
that they can learn the latest best
available knowledge
and we also
would like this report to help any
decision maker
also engineers involved in all sectors
to build on these latest science so that
they can use it and develop responses as
quickly as possible thank you
thank you valerie pettery
yes i could compliment that
the fact why
climate science is now taken
more seriously by decision makers
businesses and
finance sector is is based on the
science communication
which has been taking place since 88 the
first report
but besides that we have started seeing
the impacts of climate change and
and it's already visible it was more
theoretical
in the 80s the the impacts were not so
visible but now they are
and and that's why we are in a much
better position
uh when it comes to mitigation the the
problem is understood
the only question is how quickly we are
able to react and
luckily we have now better technical
means and also financial means to be
successful in mitigation but we are not
you're not yet there
thank you patrick greg
yeah i just thank you i wanted to just
add to what valerie said in terms of the
the way that this report attempts to
communicate to different audiences so
the report is structured with kind of
three levels of communication there's
the the summary for policymakers which
is aimed at a very high level audience
uh policymakers decision makers the
general public
then we have the technical summary which
is
about 60 pages or so that is aimed at at
a more specialist audience but not
the the really the scientific community
per se
and then we have the underlying chapters
which are
each
each much longer and cover all of the
subjects in much more detail so for
specialists or for
people looking for information on a
particular topic where they can get much
more detail the underlying chapters
provide that so depending on the kind of
information you want the the level of
expertise that different readers have
the report aims to to provide that kind
of information to all and then it's
supplemented by this interactive atlas
that uh pamau described uh early on in
the in the uh presentation that allows
users to not just read the report but
really look at the data in different
ways that are relevant to them and i
think that's really an innovation for
this report
thank you greg edwin
yes thank you for my time i think the
most absolute
innovation in this report is the atlas
chapter
atlas is very new and then we don't
present a picture or pdf
pdf paper but we present
people can animate or can make
understanding better so people can go
through the what what happened in the
climate change this year
but even this year this is enough
information because
there are a lot of information that
people can see
this is very interactive
interactive
we believe that this kind of
experience in the atlas can develop
further in the future ipcc report that
can be in the new technology in the
future this is the most uh orphan's
innovation in this report i think the
second one is like paul mentioned and
probably in the presentation that
one third of the
report
is dedicated to the regular issue this
is exactly the
what people the government wants this is
what we designed at the beginning
the whole chapter
and one third of the chapter uh four out
of 12 chapter will be
dealing with the
uh regional issue this is another
innovation that is much more and then we
did we didn't have this kind of too much
information for regional issue in the
past for the regular issue uh in this
report we compared to the
higher five thank you very much
thank you edwin
um now from thomas hebsgod of zetland in
denmark media coverage can sometimes
give the impression we would need to
stay within 1.5 degrees or face climate
catastrophe
so how should one think about the
possibility of crossing that threshold
how should we think about continued
efforts to stop further warming even if
we pass 1.5 degrees
i think valerie first but others maybe
if if you look at the um the evidence
and the scientific information provided
in this report
what is very clear is that many changes
increase with any additional fraction of
warming
so if you think of a 1.5 warmer world
our report shows that
we need to be prepared
for going into that level of warming in
the coming decades
but we can avoid further levels of
warming by acting on on greenhouse gas
emissions and that's also a very
important message from the report
when you look at regional information
when you look at how the climate system
operates
there's now a single line you know where
before that you
avoid change and after that you have a
very fast change what we show in this
report is that with any increment of
further warming you have further transit
in temperature precipitation in every
region for the melt of glaciers of
arctic sea ice
further increase in the frequency and
intensity of extreme events
and this is the information we provide
to decision makers so that they
carefully consider
the choices that they would like to make
regarding climate change
thank you jan please
yes um let me also point um to the
separate chapter we have in this report
on short-lived climate forces and these
chapters address
pollutants aerosols
together with climate or greenhouse
gases and that gives a holistic view on
the two issues climate change and the
air quality so that is i would say
something new in this report and um we
hope that it can be of use for the
policy makers to see these issues
together
thank you
thanks thanks jan
hey from sonia sanchez of our newspaper
in barcelona extreme events that now
happen once every 10 years or every 50
years will be more frequent
is it possible to put the recent floods
in germany in one of these two
categories and the heat wave in eastern
mediterranean that's causing fires is it
one of these events how much more
frequently will they happen
yes i know i can take
first let's say
in our report ways we were clearly
stating that human-induced climate
change
is already
affecting
many extreme weather and climate
events so in every regions
across the world
the evidence
are observed you know that changes
such as heat waves heavy precipitation
drought
say it's clear saying climate change and
human influences
influence the climate system also
influence the
occurrence of the
extreme events
however you know for
for
recent events
we have not assessed because ipcc
assessment is based on literature
and our cut-off data is
generated 31st for the published paper
so
in that aspect the recent events
although they they they may have you
know a clear connection to the climate
change background but we have not
assessed we so we cannot very clearly
say
which individual
event is
you know how much contribute to that
climate change
in our assessment report we have another
another statement saying
something some recent
hot extreme event observed the
events you know
saying
over there
the recent past you know
have seen extreme
extremely unlikely
to occur without human influence
on the climate system
so that
means we also not exclude you know human
influence
on the
uh extreme event we have today but
that we haven't assessed the recent
events yet i think maybe in r7
we can look at
further and make it more clearly thank
you
thank you pamela valerie
um yes thank you jonathan
the report is very clear that with
further warming in the coming years we
expect to see new extremes that are
unprecedented in magnitude frequency
timing or in regions that have never
encountered those types of extremes
and i think
an important
aspect that is shared by all the authors
of this report all the scientists
is that you know for decision making
worldwide many people just look
backwards what was the extreme event of
the last 30 years of the last 100 years
but in a changing climate that is not
sufficient it's really important to take
into account these new types of extremes
these intensified extremes that are
going to happen in the coming years or
decades and let me finish by one example
with gradual sea level rise the extreme
sea level events that occurred in the
past just once per century will occur
more and more frequently in the future
for most coastal places um worldwide
those that occurred only once per
century in the past are expected to
occur once to twice per 10 years by
mid-century and the information we
provide in this report
is extremely important to take this
information into account and to prepare
for these events thank you
thank you valerie carolina
thank you uh i would like to compliment
saying that
while it is difficult to identify the
exact causes of a particular extreme
event
there is relatively new science of event
contribution that is increasing and is
able to quantify the role of climate
change altering the probability and
magnitude of some types of weather and
climate extremes
the it's also important to mention that
the effect of climate change on extremes
is regionally different as local factors
also play an important role so uh we we
with us can only give specific
statements on events that has been
assessed but nevertheless as it was
mentioned before there is strong
evidence that characteristics of many
individual extreme events have already
changed because of human drive
changes to the climate system thank you
thank you carolina erwin
yes i encourage you to read our spm
report
there is a terminology we call it
law
likelihood high high impact event that
is our terminology low likelihood high
impact event this is part of the fbm we
will dealing and discuss very much about
the uh some
and we give some example of
what kind of event this is live low
likelihood and high impact event thank
you very much
thank you edwin
again two related questions one from uh
rhiannon williams of sky news is that
your expectation that this report will
make it easier for climate negotiators
at cop26 to achieve consensus on
ambitious targets and help nudge less
ambitious countries into action and emma
farge of reuters asks is this year's cop
26 the last chance to save us from
warming and what is the main message you
hope policymakers attending will take
from your report
valerie first
um thank you very much um
i just would like to stress that this
report has been approved by delegates
from all governments it is thus thus a
common reference
body reflecting the best state of
knowledge it is available three months
before cop 26 to be considered by
decision makers
i hope that the report helps everyone
understand climate science where we are
where we can go
and the scientists who have prepared the
report will be available and they are
they have amazing skills knowledge they
are from um all regions of the world
and i would like to invite
them to be considered as the best
ambassadors for the report to exchange
with regional national
policy makers so that this knowledge is
shared and is used
and the scientists who have prepared the
report will be also available to present
it at cop26
yeah thank you valerie um well we still
have dozens of questions oh sorry inger
wanted to come in there sorry
really to say that um
oops i let me turn on my camera here and
merely to say that uh
from therefore based on the science and
based on the the
data that is now available
it behooves every every political figure
and every decision maker be it in the
company be it in local government in
city government or indian national
government
to look at their their climate actions
to look at the emissions reductions to
assess how they can be a contributor and
to report that into the conversations
that is going to be happening at cop26
for governments obviously through the
ndc's
but for others including companies to
set up a science-based targets against
which they can measure their own
performance um and and to ensure
that business as usual does not become
the continuation so cop 26 is very
critical
obviously the scientist does not tell
the politicians what to do but they
provide the very basis for people
to have an understanding
and i would encourage that all recall
that as citizens we have a role too
in requesting and ensuring that our
governments are aware of that science
let me stop here thank you
thank you inga fatima please
yeah thank you
and on the massages from the reports i
would like to uh recall important one of
the most important results is that with
every additional increment of global
warming changes in extremes continue to
become larger
and
with more
yeah to become larger
larger
and
these may be linked to both
adaptation and mitigation
requests
thank you
thank you fatima well maybe we've only
had a couple of minutes to go but maybe
we can squeeze in one or two more
questions so from seth borenstein of the
ap
um which of the five emission scenarios
would you say the path humanity is now
on
and is it a notable accomplishment that
for the first time humanity is not on
the worst case 8.5 scenario
wanted to come in on that last question
so do you want to do that first
would you like to come in on the last
question all of a sudden
before you close the meeting please give
me the floor yeah sure
um so the question the question from
seth foreign scene of ap which of the
five emission scenarios would you say we
are now on and is it a great
accomplishment for the first time we're
not in the worst 8.5 scenario
valerie
so in this report we report the assessed
response of global temperature and sea
level in a consistent way with our
assessment of climate sensitivity to
five illustrative scenarios
it is not the mandate of physical
climate scientists to assess
the plausibility or the feasibility of
scenarios per se
i can still flag that
the high and very high emission
scenarios are in the absence of
additional climate policies
i can also flag that in the 1.5 special
report in 2018
it was shown that the pledges from
governments in 2015 would lead to global
greenhouse gas emissions
stagnated stagnating at at a level close
to today until 2030
which
would
more look like the illustrative
intermediate scenario that we are using
and and that scenario leads to reach and
surpass two degrees of global warming by
2050.
the next ipcc reports that are scheduled
for the beginning of next year will
provide much much more information on on
mitigation pathways as well as on
adaptation responses that are extremely
important to inform decision making and
action
thank you valerie and before we close
i'll give the word to wasteland please
thank you jonathan i believe some of our
audiences outside in this
room
may wonder why the ipcc does not comment
on the specific policies of our member
government
and as you probably have seen the other
international organizations such as iea
or iaea or imf
do such things
but we don't do such things we are
policy
neutral because
ipcc is a multi-layer assessment body
so does
we are not
advocating or
negating any specific policy of our
member government i hope
there is no misunderstanding in our
position thank you very much
thank you very much for that reminder
huisan was very useful
um well we've reached the end of our
time and sorry if we didn't get to all
your questions today there were many
more there but there'll be plenty of
other opportunities in the coming weeks
and months when we present the report
including at cop26
whether we're doing that virtually or in
person or in a hybrid and we'll be
working together with the wmo and the uk
met office in a joint pavilion there
where we'll be able to discuss this
report in detail as well as other events
at the cop
so and as valerie just mentioned we have
the ipcc working group two and three
reports coming out in february and march
next year so thank you and see you again
soon that ends this press conference
you